all right so what I'm going to do is in
the
end review with my Desi
here
um some of the
basic um energetic alchemical skills
that need to be developed we'll see how
far we get today but hopefully we can
get um through releasing and relaxation
to ground vectrin on the midfoot and
then maybe even to uh Coq projection and
we'll see okay um but to set up the
context I would like to review of what
we are doing and why okay uh what we're
doing uh of course because it's a
concentric
art there are three aspects to it you
have a physical aspect an energetic
aspect and a a spiritual aspect and
those three things are not causal to
each other they are concentric to each
other so they're not steps you go
through um there are there are states of
skill or states of experience okay and
they either happen simultaneously or
they don't happen at all you don't get
them at all you don't get one
okay but the end goal is not the
physical not the
Marshall um nor is the end goal the
energetic
aspects um to do cyu or II or fagin or
or adhesion no uh the end goal is divine
communion what the Marshall and the
energetic components
do
is due to a concentric understanding of
the
cosmos it is
posited that for example a Divine
communion has an energetic value let's
let's say it's a value of x
okay you can
theoretically learn how to gain the
energetic value of x through the
energetic components of the art and
thereby Prime yourself
for experiencing the spiritual component
of the art okay again my point of view
is I don't know about that I have no
that's not my experience that's not the
experience of anyone I research but I I
do know that theoretically it's held to
be
so
okay um my experience and of the people
that I research is they have a Divine
communion experience
and from there they end up developing
the other two components
okay what I
would maybe hold is
that what the energetic component does
and this is this is where I'm landing
right now right um who knows where I'll
be as my practice develops what I do
hold is not that the energetic component
will lead to Divine communion
but that it brings an agency to your
Divine communion meaning you can
generate it uh at will and maintain it
regardless of your environmental
conditions so I do think that is
possible okay but the takeaway here is
the three components of training are
concentric to each other then the second
takeaway is there is an energetic value
to Divine communion Divine communion is
the goal of the training but we train in
these other components the energetic and
the
physical because
concentrically we are achieving for
example that energetic value of divine
communion and in the end I would
conclude achieving that or being able to
achieve that does bring some
agency to Divine communion for the
practitioner
okay so simply put our main goal is
communion with God again I have a
problem
with um the way a lot of teachers
attempting
to pass on these Technologies of self
which are from Silk Road
culture but they don't want to use the
GW or the RW because they're good
modernist okay I saw a talk today by
that one um Shaolin monk that started a
temple in Germany I don't know if you
guys have seen him and his student asked
him do you have to be
religious and he's all he doesn't want
to say he doesn't want to say yes you
know he's he's kind of going oh you need
you just need something that is bigger
than you that's more important than you
he could be nature and like nature is
not more important than us
um we we we fix nature right we we we
manipulate nature it's like give me a
break that's not what it is that that's
what kishatu did he's all it could be a
creature it could be that probably not
probably not the way the ego tripartite
mind works is you can't have
something that is just a greater version
of you it can't be and so hence God in
the true sense of the word is not a
super version of us do you see um that's
the whole point of job job made the
mistake that God's a super version of us
and that's the whole lesson that's the
oldest book in the Bible um and that
that this is a beginner mistake in the
spiritual past and then also to note uh
the word religion uh before it became a
bad word just noted what is the central
practice of your life by which are you
defining and governing your decisions
and the point is everyone has a religion
that's how that monk should have
answered him but he's a good European
now and he he's very secular okay so he
can't he can't deal with it so we're
just going to be upfront we're talking
about communion with God however your
understanding of God you have to figure
out what I mean I can tell you what you
mean is not what I mean and how do I
know that because you can't do what I
can do if you if you had the
understanding you'd have the experience
and if you had the experience you could
do what I could do
okay so the way the technology of self
works is communion with God is
equivalent to a release of self or in
our discourse a sensation of the ego
tripartite mind
okay uh and that stands in contrast to
self attachment or
egocentricity if we're looking here on
the right or an unconscious domination
of your worldly experience how you
experien the world of the ego tripartite
mind okay or you can look at it another
way and it's a very uh intuitive way of
looking at it um there are three demons
that are closing you off from
God and you either possessed by these
demons or you've gained victory of these
demons and what you what is interesting
about the Demonic discourse is as you
become closer to Divine communion you
will face greater and greater
obstacles um and this is why a lot of
the mystics talk in this kind of
demonic uh discourse so even the Buddha
as he was about to have his Awakening
experience was contacted by the king of
demons okay uh because it just is that
way uh you could Define it if you have a
problem with that you could Define it in
a secular way and just go but it's very
metaphysical so good luck with that you
could say that as the universe is trying
to balance itself out as one being is
becoming
more connected to the light the darkness
steps up and tries to balance itself out
okay but it's very important to
understand I think it is very useful to
understand things through this demonic
discourse okay these three demons as you
understand them possession by the three
demons is it's a kind of unconscious
thing in the sense that you don't have
control over it okay you you kind of
fall victim to it um but what are they
they're self-attachment self self
orientation self idolatry okay what are
they they're fear pride and
ignorance every time you have fear and
pride you're going to have
egocentricity and ignorance here is well
that I misspelled that didn't I uh
ignorance here is going to be uh
unawareness and
disbelief in what I just describe to you
okay and that's like the king demon the
other two you might think are the more
Danger Dangerous Ones but the king demon
is the ignorance so you're totally
unaware that the other two demons have
you
okay so we develop practices in a way
that combat
egocentricity okay that's what we're
trying to do because of our ultimate
goal Divine communion okay and we have
mentioned that there are these kind of
ongoing background
practices which I have made akin to
modernday aestheticism so if you wore an
anchorite a mountain athetic a yamabushi
or whatever you'd be doing something of
this nature okay and you can see that
all these
practices basically occupy the whole of
your day the way a monastic code
would and do so in a way in such a way
that you're doing battle with those
demons fear pride and ignorance okay why
because you're trying to get gain a
release a release from the self okay and
so we have uh why do I call them
negative practices or background
practices because they take up the whole
of your day and really their main
um viability comes from they occupy your
day so that you're not
in possession or being possessed by fear
pride and ignorance so that most of your
training for example or most of your
life or most of your daily experience is
in battle with those three demons and
not in possession of those three demons
so for example when you practice the
four disciplines you might look at them
positively such as sleep hygiene 8 to n
hours a day but to follow a regiment for
example of daily training four to six
hours a day
plus a sleep hygiene of 8 to n hours a
day that leaves you very little time to
Netflix binge for example do you see and
to to distract yourself from your lack
of divine communion with popular culture
and worldly inertia and things like that
okay you become very monastic so to
speak so these kind of like yes there's
positive aspects to them but it's really
the negative aspects in that if you
follow them you won't be allowed to do
the other things what things those
things that fear pride and ignorance
will make you want to do okay such as
distraction so a lot of times we're
suffering from anxiety and depression
and what we want to do instead of
addressing the self- attachment that is
at the source of those mood disorders
we'll distract ourselves we'll distract
ourselves with uh political AC activism
entertainment worldly trivia Etc and we
let go the work that needs to be done
okay so these things are running in the
background as I would say if you don't
know that this is the goal of the
training you probably won't be training
in a way to produce the results that you
see me do if you're unaware the
ignorance has you there's no way you can
get close to what you see me do okay
likewise if you're not practicing these
negative practices if these are not
constituting your daily
existence it's going to be
difficult to do what you see me do it's
going to be near impossible okay they're
not extra practices they are at the core
of it okay as far as what do I
do here's what I am aiming for a what do
I do start here
okay if you understand what you're
supposed to do and then you start here
now you have a true
Catalyst for these positive practices
that we're going to do okay that we want
to
generate uh and manifest things okay and
why okay why
here's why I believe this is
important is everyone can understand
this and everyone can say they're doing
this but if you truly can experience
this and you truly are doing this then
you can do these positive practices okay
because it's a concentric rule okay and
so just like today everyone can Shout
out their loyalty and Devotion to Jesus
but we will know by who gets on the
cross when it's time to get on the cross
and that is all that we would say has
Devotion to Christ but
likewise this these energetic practices
take everything we've just
discussed and then put it to the test
okay not until post Enlightenment did
our religious
systems become
ideational prior to that everything had
these three components and those three
components work as checks and
balances and hence a modern guy here in
Southern California can look at these
checks and balance and go we're going to
put it to the test okay we're going to
put it to the test why because for
example
uh coku and
iy require a release of
self
okay and when we do coku and II in pair
training fear and pride and ignorance
are being brought to the table so here
in the dojo just like the Buddha said I
teach suffering and how to get out of
suffering likewise here in budo I teach
fear pride and ignorance and I teach you
how to get out of fear pride and
ignorance okay in
budo we don't want you might want to out
of Pride and out of fear and obviously
out of ignorance you might want to
combat these demons and slay them but
that's not how this works okay victory
over the demons is through
reconciliation and this this
reconciliation is at the heart of one
the reconciliation between the ego
tripartite mind and the god mind which
allows for divine communion but at the
Marshall component or the physical
component this is a Reconciliation of
Yin and yangong and it manifests through
non-c contestation there at the bottom
hence why jiujitsu looks like jiujitsu
Judo looks like it keto all the
derivatives of the Japanese Arts look
and use non-c contestation okay well
when we look at koku and II we've gone
to the energetic level we're not at the
the physical level we should still see
non-c
contestation and it takes the shape of Y
energy passing through the contact Point
through your body
internalizing it okay and that shape
will not that that uh internalization of
Yang aspect will not happen if you are
physically and emotionally abiding in
fear pride and ignorance God cannot get
into you because there's three demons in
you there's no space okay to use the
Demonic discourse okay so we know for
example we will know whether you still
have fear and pride in you when someone
pushes on you and whether you have
ignorance over the fact that there is
not two people here there's only one all
that will manifest on whether you can do
these skills or not okay so we have to
in developing these skills we have to
aim towards that we're going to
internalize this so internalize Yang
aspect is the ultimate non-c
contestation that non-c contestation is
concentric with with God entering
you got got that okay Yi is heaveni
heaveni in Chinese uh religious
discourse before uh it was heaven heaven
was God and in older manuscripts it
still is God
okay it's not a place in other
words so Yang aspect is concentric with
God coming into you um
and that is concentric with those demons
going out of
you and this is the ultimate form of
communion because it is the ultimate
form of non-c contestation okay in other
words an external Yin yield is not non
contestation it's not there's still
contestation in there there's still
still dichotomy in there there's still
the ego tripartite mind that's at work
okay so we're going to do some exercises
that first help you relax and ultimately
release okay relax we're just going to
keep it mundane it's muscle tension
that's what we're going to deal with um
again there's no way you can have
communion with god with muscle tension
but muscle tension is I wouldn't say
it's the pathway to communion go with
God it's just you can't be there okay
likewise there can't be released with
muscle tension there can't be the
spiritual
uh skill of releasing what is
releasing uh detaching from self okay
there cannot be the spiritual skill of
releasing with muscle tension so hence
we start with muscle relaxing drills
okay and that's where we're going to go
now okay uh so my first drill I I'll
teach it to him okay my first drill is
we're going to use uh some of those
loosening uh
those warmup exercises we went we had a
video recently on them okay so he's
going to come out here and uh I first I
want to
fix um his body to prime it
for um releasing for relaxing okay and
this is a poetic so be careful that your
egot triar type mind is going to want to
understand this seally or physically it
there is a physical component but
concentrically there's an energetic
component and a spiritual component if
there wasn't the other two components if
there was only a physical component it
would not do what we needed to do okay
so be careful everything I'm saying here
is a poetic meaning it's upaya meaning
I'm saying something to get him to
experience something to feel something
okay but he has no context for that
feeling and and I have to continually
adapt what I'm saying to get the feeling
in his person okay so to get ourselves
in the ballpark um I'll have him stand
with his feet underneath his
hips okay and I'll give him a physical
reference I want his feet straight so I
want his middle toe to be straight okay
if this is extremely uncomfortable for
him I'll let him put his feet a little
wider but definitely no wider than
shoulder width okay uh the physical
parameters are if he goes really
wide I don't want the structure of his
weight concaving his
arch or requiring him to flex to keep
his arch from concaving okay so if his
feet are really wide he has has to have
flexion like in a horse dance to get
that to work and we don't want flexion
right now okay and if he's really
narrow right it's the same thing his
feet are there's pressure on the outside
of his feet and in order to keep his
feet from to be flat I have
to uh open up his feet okay and I don't
want him to flex I don't want him going
and rolling of here like this they're
inside my hip the weight wants to spill
out people have to go no we don't want
that okay so I like to start with the
hip line right straight down from the
hips and then to use the middle
toe
okay and then I'm going to give him a
spot to concentrate
on and again this will be first
physically it is right
here
right
there right
there on the bottom of his foot so hold
my head and give me your leg
okay it's right
here that is where I want him to write
now cuz he's just a br we're pretend
he's brand new a brand new person has to
do this consciously
okay I want you to
consciously let your body weight
fall being pulled by gravity onto that
spot on your foot got it I want your
middle toe
straight and I'm not asking you to to
take your heel off the ground a lot of
beginners will do
that if I'm honest about that spot your
heel will stay on the ground most people
that take their heel off the ground
you're forward of that spot got it okay
and now what I want you to do I'll give
several
imageries one is either a
hook through the crown of his head okay
and when we say the crown of the head we
don't mean the top of his head here we
mean the chakra in the back back here
okay
a hook through this top
chakra pulling your spine
up or you can do a hook here at the
medulla amang but you can't let this go
okay this part stays
still and from that hook it's got energy
going up your spine
up let that hook hold you and everything
everything drops gravity
pulls and you just balance on that spot
letting everything drop release
relax so as I watch him now there's a
couple things that I know he's not
doing his torso is too
straight pay
attention can you see how straight it is
okay I want you to release and relax
your lower legs and let yourself fall
when you eventually fall don't don't
flex them just fall let your weight take
you don't flex your feet don't you just
R you see how he came back forward okay
so he can't he can't do it I don't know
camera could you see see that come back
forward I know Chris saw it come back
forward why' he come back forward
because he's falling backwards
okay so and the reason he's falling
backwards is because this is not where
this needs to be so this hook imagery or
this hook imagery is not working for him
okay another place you can put the hook
is right here okay this is
pulling okay but I'm going to do the
following I'm going to give just tell
him to camp this a little forward
without dropping your head and I'm going
to have you push this chin
back right where I have it so let's go
back what I'm doing I'm not having him
drop his chin I'm having him move his
head back do you see that okay and
they'll be a slight tuck to the
chin and then I want you to bring this
slightly
towards the
forward and now if you pay attention
he's going like this do you see that and
that is what you want okay that is the Y
energy hitting the ground and coming
back up and pulsing through his body so
he
he his body's going
boom boom kind of exaggerating it it
kind of goes boom boom boom boom boom
okay that energy is now going up and
down to the new person it's going to
feel like you're going to fall forward
okay what you have to do is not flex and
then let your body come back from
falling what you think is going to be
falling from the rebounding Chi hitting
the ground
okay that and that's the hard part
because the fear of falling makes you
Flex you you get it and so this is why
this is a limal practice in this limal
practice alone you have to release the
fear if you don't release the fear the
energy will not bounce back off the
ground and you will actually fall
forward okay you will fall
forward
okay all right and so let's try that Dr
and it's tiring it is tiring at first um
but this is something you can
extend uh two
minutes you know you you have people
that will do this thing for two hours 20
minutes Etc again once you know how to
do it you you don't I don't think you
need to do this I think chrish mury is
right um when he says like uh what was
it 2 minutes or 20 minutes he gave he
gave not 20 minutes 2 minutes or 20
seconds like that's all you need to do
uh is to periodically have these moments
of uh uh Divine communion okay just
interrupt your day with them I think he
said like two minutes two minutes is
pretty good 20 minutes is long um but
you might need that because just like
everything else you you might not feel
your tension until you go longer into
the practice where the tension can't be
upheld any longer okay but I think when
you're doing 2 hours I think that's a
little bit overkill for me but again you
might need that okay all right so let's
try this
drill okay so some key areas for tension
and and their easy their easiness to get
rid of is going to be this part on your
arms right there
okay next is going to be the root of the
tongue
okay next is your
glutes and your
gloin a little more difficult is going
to be back
here in the lumbar region of your
[Music]
spine and then very very hard to
do is this spot back here on the lower
legs okay of course the beginner will be
tense everywhere but I'm like I'm giving
you the major key points to get rid of
so like a beginner might be flexing
their feet it's like that's too that's
too far down that's too far low okay
what I would recommend for that person
is that you do this in Corpse pose you
you learn the how to release muscle
tension in Corpse pose with
no uh fear of Falling On Deck okay and a
beginner might have to do that um
releasing in Corpse pose I'm not
knocking it I I I actually take
advantage of that uh every day I do
those releasing from there but every
time you add or you work with one of the
Demons your cultivation is better okay
so when you add that fear of falling
you're going to generate more release
than if you were in Corpse pose but uh
there's structurally there's nothing
wrong with corpse pose and you may have
to do it okay um of course you would do
this all the time and seated you do the
same thing in seated uh you're working
the same way at that level of your zand
training okay all right uh we're going
to go
up and you're going to be in h
me
okay and so now he's not Square to me
he's got a a front foot and a back foot
okay and we're going
to keep his extension here
okay and you can see that I'm generating
what the ego triart type mind will see
as a dichotomy but if he's doing this
right it will not be a dichotomy so
again you have your stressor
dichotomous mind functioning and his job
is to not fall victim to that de demon
and to reconcile that okay so in this
we're going to have him do that same
midfoot grounding but he only gets one
leg to do it and it's the back leg okay
so um I first I don't want you you're
already pushing me away so don't do that
don't let me have your hands okay they
don't put your hands out there and
that's already contesting okay all right
and now I will push you onto that back
leg got it so you have your weight is on
both legs and then I will push you onto
that
okay now all the weight that you were
dropping before you should drop there so
you have all your young aspect that you
were dropping before and that should
feel the same stay there please stay
there so don't change the things that
you needed at the beginning okay boom
and there was a forward tilt to the
Torso got it so just like you were
dropping
there let all that drop till you feel
the pulse on that the pulsating of the
Yi on the back foot
okay and now my y will join that y as
long as you keep your mind there and not
contest me okay you you're going to have
to reach out
some it's going over the top Let It Drop
onto that foot this pressure is pushing
your foot down look your eyes straight
at my
chest reach out more
turn these up a
little good stay there it's dropping on
that midfoot dropping on the mid
foot everything's just pushing that foot
down straight down extend again more
turn them up more stay there
now stay
there lean a little forward on your
torso okay drop that knee
more there you go reach out again why do
you keep doing that ex turn them up more
do you feel my pressure doing that I
want you to do that let it
happen look up Don't Look
[Music]
Down lock your torso
forward
keep letting it drop onto that midfoot
keep that right knee on the Y phase even
with your
toes and
out okay so he's on
me what whatever he wants to do with my
arms doesn't matter and I'm going to be
on on that one foot okay he's pushing
and I'm on that
foot so it's not my base that's
important that's what I'm trying to
demonstrate there it's that midfoot
there but I can be in h
me so I'd like to bring that left knee
to the Yang line that's the toe line
just to start out with and I organize
everything up
top
so that all my weight is dropping onto
that midfoot as if I'm doing a solo
drill such that if he lets go really
fast I wouldn't go flying forward okay
weight is just going down now the
ignorance demon wants to tell you that
there's no way that this linear Force
that's going that way could go down got
that and and so your ability to believe
him or
not come on over
here is based on
your level of bti
yoga how much fop and devotion do you
have to your teacher that's the world
right there okay if you can't do it
towards your teacher there's no freaking
way you can do it to what I mean by God
okay I will put this before
you between your wrist and your
feet I would say there's countless
joints I would not be able to count them
okay I would also say that there's
fluids of varying
viscosities and Cavities of various
vacuum sizes and pressures that I could
not
calculate but it looks to me that
somewhere in that
uncountable joints points of
articulation with undeterminable or
unquantifiable viscosity for multiple
fluids and multiple vacuum pressures I
bet somewhere in there you could Vector
this
inertia and not have it be a slave to
the straight angle
okay to help get you in the ballpark all
right okay let's try
it okay so as I said pre-enlightenment
religion uh always had checks and
balances built in because they didn't
function purely at the ideational level
uh so there were always body practices
physical practices and they were always
held to be more insightful in terms of
your spiritual practice or lack thereof
so the cool thing about budo is it's not
ideational except for those who are
doing it incorrectly it has a practice
component it has a body component and so
we can test for validity there okay um
so you can do for example you can do
let's say you're a
neon practitioner and you can do this
standing standing meditation and then
you can start telling yourself that
you're doing it that's that's very
problematic to me okay and so we do do
solo training but here we don't
emphasize solo training precisely
because can I tell do I know okay so we
start putting a partner training so we
value more partner training than solo
training and when it comes to partner
training we value more the live training
environments than we do the controlled
environments okay so we wish went from a
solo practice which I do recommend you
should do uh and you should start there
but um if you can't do what we're doing
now in the paired practice you probably
weren't doing it I'm going to say you
weren't doing it you weren't doing it in
a Solo practice okay you need more work
okay so when he's here and he's driving
me uh and the same way that I'm relaxed
everything is relaxed you might see at
this level as you saw his arms kept
going in and I had to keep telling him
to go out you might see that he's still
materially understanding uh releasing so
when he tried to relax his arms come in
okay but that's not releasing that's
still a material understanding of
releasing uh releasing again is a
spiritual thing it's a a a sensation of
the ego tripartite mind okay so so uh
what I would ask you to do is now task
yourself
with um I'm going to keep my shape but
I'm going to release muscle tension
again give yourself something mundane to
work on I keep releasing muscle tension
but I cannot lose my shape okay so for
example in the solo
drill I want you to keep releasing
muscle tension without coming off the
hook
okay so likewise
here my hands are here in the katata uh
arm extension which if you don't know
where it is uh release bend over
release and you're going to see a
natural Bend in your
elbow and that's where you have that
bend there so I have to keep that bend
there he's
driving I can't move in space obviously
sagittally across the mat but I won't
let him move my arms either okay and as
I keep this shape again there's it's not
a two um footed stance so there's no
bracing angle to
it I start releasing or relaxing all
muscle tension that I
can without giving up the shape so
everything is if you go ahead and you
you can get your big basee you want okay
um you can squeeze my arms there squeeze
my mushy arms do you feel how they're
mushy okay um I have my fingers in this
shape but I'm not tensing The Palms The
Palms are very relaxed and I'm just
keeping that
shape
all right so let's add that to the drill
go okay so what what if you remember
when you're doing this eventually you'll
feel like a fear that you're going to
fall just keep releasing and you'll feel
the yangong chi which now converts to
Yin chees it hits the Earth it comes
back up up okay now that's Yin your
tanden is actually formed but you're not
aware of it and so we're not asking you
to be aware of it at this point okay but
when I go here as he's pushing what's
actually pushing back on him is that
same yongi coming off the floor that's
why it's more that it's coming
out of me do you see not him coming into
me okay and the more relaxed I am the
more that comes the more he comes in and
the more that comes out okay so what I
want to do now is my weight's on the
back foot what I want to do now is merge
with that coming
out shift my
weight so I'll let it load boom and then
shift my weight boom
and at this on this drill it's probably
going to go somewhere around the
shoulders or chest I don't give a
where later in Kon wo where do we aim
it yeah always through their tonden
field okay um so this one I don't care
where it is same thing he's driving
there and you're going to eventually
shift and moveing forward again you
don't see me falling I just come on to
the other foot and you're in basically
your EDI stance
okay room
ground
move okay let's try okay so in the same
way like uh as he's I have maybe the
fear falling that makes me tense on the
solo drill and here the the the
contestation I have is somebody pushing
on me or maybe the ignorance regarding
two Dimensions here um the same way now
that I've given myself a goal you see I
have a
desire um and so I have a fear that I
don't achieve my desire and this is
playing with the demon okay so you have
to as you as you uh move him you don't
move him you just move you don't worry
about him okay because I don't want any
tension to come into to my body no
tension into my
body no desire everything stays
relaxed relaxed okay try that again go
okay so let me clarify um I have the Y
Line here the knee to toe line there
okay and when I shift weight I'm going
to go to that same knee to toe line
that's it okay don't shift past it you
take weight off that is where you're now
just trying to move him
okay so knee knee to toe line the Y
Line and then same thing over here
that's all I go that's it okay and so
now you can see the the boat rowing
exercise okay one
boom and now you can understand non-
contestation energetically so he's
pushing it's not me pushing on him it's
going going through me this is the
ultimate non-c contestation and then
same thing here it's not me him pushing
on me it's me going through
him
okay let's try it again obey that young
line to give you some context for what
you're doing my my people are doing it
here um and this is how it goes again to
me this comes back to this
one comes back to Bak yoga
okay um I think that's why it's also
very coincidental that no one can do
these skills in contempor iido and no
one wants or has a true Sensei Desi
relationship anymore okay um and so you
got to constantly be correcting through
Poetics through
ha uh the the way they're being
over by these demons
okay so we already said what he's doing
he's pushing he's pushing he's he's not
g gentle he's really P he's really
pushing me
okay and he doesn't stop doing that just
cuz he's going the other way okay he's
pushing that hard and
and I I'm just
moving okay it's not that he he's here
and now now he he gets ready to go
backwards not it or he gently pushes and
then I gently push him backwards he's
he's driving he's driving the F out of
me okay but I'm just going through
it okay uh and once you once you can do
that you don't even have to do the
absorption
part got it because we're not contesting
he's coming in and I can go
in coming
in okay and I don't have to do the Y
young that's just a beginner drill okay
but we're never going to get there if my
Catalyst isn't doing their job okay
let's try it again